nobody's sitting because of a blowout
here's graham
to get to washington again alex caruso
he's got it
scored with the slam
the career show
[Applause]
he was going to rondo on that play did a
great job
stolen by hardin goes up inside blocked
by caruso
from behind terrific recovery and
defensive play for caruso caruso does a
great job coming
from the back court chase down block
james got it out to caldwell pogue
caruso you didn't know he had that in
his bag did you
well alex caruso is more athletic than
you think
and he worked hard on his body goes to
the room with authority and leaves no
doubt
lebron james clearing the lane wide open
to get that
layup ball turns it over collision with
his teammate
[Applause]
oh why wouldn't they right here caruso
able to get himself
inside the lane and show off some of
that i can do it
getting the angle on white side right
side not able to get over to contest
that shot
again alex caruso he's got it
[Applause]
look at that puts his hand out knocks
down the flat angle
runs it down and then hammers one
gets this crowd all worked up make
yourself in other
[Applause]
watch him step straight in see nobody's
boxing out kyle and anderson just
stepped straight to the free throw line
and
caruso says look i cannot jump you it
does
charmand jackson and lyle
all three of those should be on one
banner
ac's got it ac
and he did a great job
[Applause]
this shot by danny green dwight thinks
he's got an offensive rebound all of a
sudden
here comes caruso nobody put a body on
him and he put a highlight play
up into the stands here
what up it's your boy adam lefkow did
you like that content i know you like
that content hit subscribe
for more of it from bleach report